it'd be funny if there's a
freedom of speech switch that you could
also control
and there would be a perfect metaphor
well that's different because
what they figured out is is that if they
can just make sure that we don't have
any public options for communication
then
hey every pri every thing that we say to
each other goes to a private company
private companies can do whatever they
want
and this is like one of the greatest
moves that we didn't really notice
electronic and digital speech makes
every other kind of speech irrelevant
and because there is no public option
uh guess what there's always somebody
named sundar or jack
or mark who controls whether or not you
can speak
and what it appears to be that is being
said and whose stuff is weighted more
highly than others
it's an absolute nightmare and by the
way the silicon valley
intellectual elite lord knows what is
going on people are so busy making money
that they are not actually upholding any
of the values
so silicon valley is sort of maximally
against it it has this kind of
libertarian
free progressive sheen to it when it
goes to burning man and then it
quickly just imposes rules on all of the
rest of us as to what we can say to each
other if we're not part of the inner
elite
so what do you think the ideal of the
freedom of speech means
well this is very interesting i keep
getting lectured on social media by
people who have no idea how much power
the supreme court has to abstract things
right now you have the concept of the
letter of the law and the spirit of the
law
and the spirit of the law would have to
say that our speech that matters is free
at least at the level of ideas i don't
claim that i have the right
to endanger your life with speech or to
reveal your private information
so i really am not opining about
directed
speech intended to smear you and
[Music]
that's a different kettle of fish and
maybe i have some rights to do that but
i don't think that they're infinite
um what i am saying is is that the
freedom of speech for ideas
is essential that the court abstract it
and shove it down the throat
of google facebook twitter amazon
whoever these infrastructure companies
are because
it really matters which abstraction you
use the the case that i really like
is search and seizure if i have private
data
that i entered in my house that is
stored on a server that you hold
outside of my house but i view the
is the abstraction that it's only the
perimeter of my house that i have the
right to protect
or does my password extend
the perimeter of my house to the data on
the server that is located outside of my
house
these are court are choices for the
court and the court is supposed to
pretend that they can define the true
intent of the framers
but all of the sort of and i have taken
to calling this the problem of internet
hyenas people with ready-made answers
and
lols and you're such a these folks
love to remind you it's a private
company dude can do whatever it wants
no the court has to figure out what the
abstractions are
and just the way for example the
griswold decision
um found that there was a penumbra
because there was too little in the
constitution therefore there were all
sorts of things implied that couldn't be
in the document
somebody needs to come up with the
abstraction right now
that says uh jack cannot do whatever he
wants
it's really so you say the courts but
it's also us
people who think about the world see you
it's the courts
but the courts don't do this we're toast
but we can still think about it i mean
uh sure
but i i don't feel like going down the
drain here's what i'm thinking about
because it's tricky how far it should
extend
i mean that's an ongoing conversation
don't you think the interpretation of
the law
i think i'm trying to say something very
simple and it's just not going to be
popular for a while
tech dwarfs previous forms of
communication
print or shouting in a public park
and so you know i can go to a public
park and i can shout if i get a permit
even there i think was in the ninth late
1980s in atlanta
we came up with free speech zones where
you can't protest at a convention you
bet you can go to a park 23 miles out
and they'll fence off a little area
where you can have your free speech
no speech is dangerous ideas are
dangerous
we are a country about danger and risk
and yes i agree that targeted speech at
individuals trying to reveal their
private
stuff and all that kind of that is very
different so forget
a lot of that stuff but free speech for
ideas is meant to be dangerous
and people will die as a result of free
speech
the idea that one life is too much is
preposterous like why did we send
if one life is preposterous why do we
send anyone to the beaches of normandy i
just don't get this
you